they're importing a sculpture
[Music]
we've got some dirt in here
is that some grass too this was on the
ground for a long time you can tell yeah
I wouldn't consider this a handicraft I
would consider this something completely
out of that realm it's a sculpture they
have the actual dirt still falling off
from there so you can tell that it was
somewhere for a very very long time it
was dug out right from the dirt if it
came in Legally or not we don't know we
just want to make sure what it is first
so we can make that final assessment
so let's find the other pieces
this is an even bigger piece well what
do you think they're from
definitely have to call somebody on
these things lift this one up so we can
get pictures
have you ever seen anything like me it
looks like no Indiana Jones movie yeah
right yeah
the sculptures all follow very similar
patterns so it seems like one person
made this or the same group of people
made it they look like the same kind of
rock yeah same material I don't know
what kind of rock neither do I
since it no longer has any materials
related to agriculture I have to refer
it off to the inbound team to see what
further action might be needed
hey officers how are you so these are a
couple of those pictures that we found
this is awesome
so I'm with the embond enforcement team
we're a specialized unit that responds
to either artwork artifacts any type of
item that might have cultural
significance
I suspect they're monoliths
if it was new the lines would be sharper
we'd probably see tool marks but in this
case there aren't any of the fact that
it's still covered in soil we're
thinking they're an authentic artifacts
this seems like a misrepresentation they
said they're a hundred dollars each
based on other items we've seen that's
not an accurate price we could see the
line where it was buried in the soil
and people bring this into the country
because they no this is handicraft you
know like the paperwork says it's a
certificate of origin from Cameroon we'd
have to contact the cameroonian
government see if this is legitimate and
make certain it's not falsified
this could possibly be a black market if
it does belong to Cameroon the
patrimonia I would highly doubt they
would allow these items to be taken out
of the country
and now we're going to contact the
subject matter expert I got that funny
feeling it will be significant but that
that'll be yet to be determined
[Music]
thank you
[Music]